my name is Bill Burr and I feel I feel
all right
with that that is such a Massachusetts
attitude to have I feel all right well I
didn't see this last half of it I
thought it was how was I feeling oh I
didn't know it was about oh it's about
you
oh it's about Conan everybody hi my name
is Bill Burr
it feels so special
being Conan O'Brien's friends I mean it
is such a short list
a lot of people want a Grammy some
people want an Emmy not me I just want
to be Conan's friend oh well finally
happened well it's a time of years ago
we gotta see how it goes how the podcast
you told me years ago there wasn't
enough room for two redheads in this
town
I try to out Ginger me yeah no it is
true I was going to tell you that you
were your Fame is such that I was
talking to you know we talked to fans
once a week and we just released an
episode today where I talked to a fan
who's in Tehran in the middle of what's
happening there I know that guy and uh
yeah it's the same thing as growing up
in Boston anyway I was talking to him
and he was telling us all this uh really
intense stuff that's happening in Tehran
and then at one point uh he said but
Conan when things calm down I'd love it
if you came here and visited me and I
said well would I be welcome like would
kind of like would your would your
parents know who I am and he said oh all
I have to do is tell them this guy's
really funny uh and he's from boss and
he's got red hair and my parents will
say we love Bill Burr and
and then he went sing and this is a guy
who's in the middle of a terrible
Revolution and a terrible situation but
took the time to use you to zing me and
then said zing and this is from Tehran
which I thought was pretty impressive I
liked it I like that he said Zing that
probably added an extra sting to it if
he just sort of gave you [ __ ] you would
have taken that but the fact that he
went zing and went like old-timey with
it I don't know I feel like that got
under your skin
I've been doing zings for 30 years
I almost didn't release the tape of him
yeah I was like what about this is such
a terrible thing like no this is a great
you know message from someone in the
middle of a historic uh you know
turbulent time and he needs to get the
word out and like now we're not
releasing it why not he thanked me you
know just be so small of me I'd be such
a small person to do that I'm already
thinking wondering if they have a funny
bone in Iran or whatever Iraq is that
what Iraq no it's Iran oh is it Iran
that's brutal I just said what are you a
Yankees fan he's like no Red Sox